[Music]
hey Bros what does the golf team do to
those who crash our party take another
[ __ ] step and you're dead
well [ __ ] you loser I was trying to cut
it clean off it was gonna be rad that's
me
Josh and I've got a killer origin story
stuff fights drama Josh this is Sam and
love so challenging Josh wheeler and I
do like a challenge but then
so what's life like during the
apocalypse it's awesome there's no rules
left because adults turn into what we
call coolies the world is backwards I
just feel in the way battle now I'm sure
there are still jocks nerds and
cheerleaders but I have everything I
ever wanted it's about being cool as
[ __ ] Wesley fists I'm gonna pack the
redemption we are free we can do
anything I couldn't pull off those pants
[Music]
look we're all searching for something
famous out there and I'm not giving up
until I find you can't just leave us I
agree with the petulant to a few acquire
our assistance I'm making something
important here
or own tribe a family by choice so
Kurt's this is why I avoid people
your skills
Angelica's brain
my swords
ain't nothing we can't do together
[Music]
[Music]
so what's life like in the apocalypse
it's never what you'd expect
[Music]
sorry to interrupt but your sword is
still stuck in my [ __ ] hand
it's stuck in the bone boy
[Music]